martin biron michel serrault j luc
ferrandez et raphaël jacob merci d'être
là raphaël qu'on a évité compte tenu de
ce drame dans une école primaire du
texas bonjour à vous quatre
bonjour bonjour donc je répète pour ceux
qui n'étaient pas avec nous en début
d'émission 14 enfants assassinés dans la
classe l'enseignante également après
celle du hook c'est en 2012 vint enfin
qui avait été assassinée on avait dit
plus jamais dit sur obama qui avait
parti une croisade pour changer les
règles on est revenu un peu comme avant
raphaël je vous donne la parole en
premier est-ce que et monsieur bail de
ne doit parler ou entre eux doit
s'exprimer il est de retour d'asie ce
soir est-ce qu'on va assister
bien sûr
à la même colère
face à ce drame là cette fois ci la même
colère oui mais malheureusement pour les
partisans d'un resserrement du contrôle
des armes à feu aux états unis presque
assurément le même résultat c'est à dire
que rien ne bouge de façon substantielle
d'un point de vue législatif à
washington si ça n'a pas bougé en 2012
ça ne va pas plus bouger en 2022 surtout
dans ce contexte patrice ou qu'est ce
qui se passe également aujourd'hui on a
des primaires en vue des élections du 20
août pourquoi est-ce que ça c'est
important à mentionner à le contacter
dans le contexte actuel parce que si
vous êtes un électeur un candidat pardon
vous un élu républicain c'est carrément
impensable dans le contexte dit par
polarisation aux etats unis aujourd'hui
de même vous prononcer en faveur d'un
possible resserrement du contrôle des
armes à feu et les républicains sont
suffisamment nombreux au sénat
présentement washington même si
techniquement ils sont minoritaires pour
bloquer à peu près quoi que ce soit donc
oubliez ça dans le court le moyen terme
un resserrement moindrement musclée
contre les armes à feu même après cette
nouvelle au vert dans une école primaire
en ce qui me concerne c'est pratiquement
impensable donc l'association que son
congrès au texas et c'est là l'ironie et
ultime dans quelques jours et 1030 doit
y assister à l'aréna
vous ne passez pas raphaël qui va des
remises en question là ils vont dire
c'est pas larmes que tu es c'est la
personne qui était derrière mais voilà
c'est le même refrain qu'on entend
depuis en fait plus que dix ans mais
depuis dix ans par ce moment depuis
s'allier aux caisses qui est remarqué
patrice et qu' il ya à peine quoi une
semaine un peu plus d'une semaine on a
eu une autre fusillade de masse qui a
défrayé la manchette c'est d'abord flou
et qu'est-ce qu'on a eu dans ce contexte
la banlieue un des arguments les plus
fondamentaux des adversaires du contrôle
des armes à feu qui a été
essentiellement des montées parce que ce
qu'on entend très souvent c'est quoi
c'est comme vous l'avez dit premièrement
le problème c'est la personne qui est
derrière la mafia et deuxièmement si on
veut bloquer ou on veut freiner les
méchantes personnes animées qui sont
armés tout ce que ça prend ce sont des
bonnes personnes qui sont armés à à
bordeaux il y avait anguille m bonne
personne qui était armé qui était le
gardien de l'établissement c'était une
épicerie doit-on le rappeler et il s'est
fait abattre donc c'est pas je voudrais
une question de validité ou de solidité
ou de rationalité des arguments c'est
une question de mobilisation politique
la base républicaine le noyau dur et
viscéralement opposé à tour serment
prononcé du contrôle des armes à feu et
c'est ça qui anime la position des élus
et des candidats républicains presqu'un
d'un océan à l'autre présentant dans ce
pays là je suis obligé vous avez été
washington connaissait bien les états
unis cet autre drame on va donc assister
comme d'habitude à la montée aux
barricades celle du côté démocrate des
groupes qui s'occupe de ça mais
finalement malheureusement ça risque de
ne rien changer
super nous devons parler ce soir je
pense que je pourrais écrire le discours
parce qu'on le connaît sur boubam à la
faute ils ont tous fait b il ya trois
ans avec quelques millions d'habitants
aux etats-unis à plus de 4,5 millions
d'armes en circulation
même si demain matin ils ont passé une
loi pour interdire la vente d'armes à
feu c'est pas possible afin
d'appréhender dit mais même si on
faisait ça imaginez la tête qu'on fait
il y en a 400 millions qui sont en
circulation alors il ya quelque chose
d'un peu surréel évidemment chaque fois
que tu rajoutes dit comme ça ça se passe
mais il va se trouver des gens partie du
public un bon dire non non c'est
quelqu'un qui était dérangé c'est parce
que les socios son poids sur son poids
était revenue
oui effectivement il devait être
fortement dérangé a tué sa grand-mère
avant apparemment mais la question c'est
comment quelqu'un de déranger peut avoir
accès si facilement luc ferrandez à des
arbres c'est toujours le même des bols
et oui effectivement des gens qui
souffrent de maladies mentales y en a
dans le monde entier et des événements
violents il y en a dans le monde entier
mais avec une arme disponible
parce que
l'amérique
il faut dire que l'amérique en ce moment
vit des heures difficiles
doit on est revenu à un taux de meurtres
qu'on n'avait pas connu depuis les zones
de la milieu des années soixante dix un
taux de suicides aussi que beaucoup
augmenté un taux de 2
d'overdose on apprenait les chiffres
récemment le 110 mille morts par
overdose 45000 barma fut 45 mille
blessés par me fut aussi
raphaël parlait de là dessus vite barre
des mois il ya eu aussi c'est ce gars
cet homme que tu lui cette série dans le
métro de new york 23 blessés alors ya un
problème aux états unis un problème de
chaos un propre société qui a perdu ses
repères on ajoute à ça la disponibilité
des armes et martins il ya peu de drame
plus triste que des enfants qui se font
exécuter dans une salle de classe cndd
et aux classes était affreux on est à
aller quelques collègues journal et sur
place la douleur des parents est aussi
une imaginaire alors voici encore que ça
survient nouveau le sait ce qui est qui
est incroyable voyons voir vivre dans
les prochains jours c'est sûr qu'on va
tous être très touché par ce drame là
mais pour revenir au contrôle des armes
à feu c'est politiquement c'est
compliqué ce conflit aux états unis mais
c'est compliqué ici oui si on réussit un
peu mieux qu'aux états unis mais tenir
un registre des armes à feu c'est un
gros enjeu au canada et même ici au
québec il on l'a mis en place le le
gouvernement l'a mis en place le
registre des armes à feu on a beaucoup
de difficultés à mener les gens qui
détiennent des armes à feu à
s'enregistrer eux mêmes alors et
politiquement si on le voit constamment
dans ce dossier là parce qu'on sait que
c'est un sujet très sensible et qui
peuvent beaucoup de bonnes volontés
qu'effectivement on rejette toujours les
enjeux des armes à feu sur le fait que
c'est des gens des gangs organisés
on voit aussi à montréal on est beaucoup
moins dans une dangereuse de restreindre
et d'enregistrer les armes à feu on a
des difficultés à avoir finalement
contribution des gens qui ont des armes
à feu reffle en conclusion je vais vous
laisser aller parce que nos vallées sur
la loi 96 mais c'est un pays fracturée
et on le voit le cas avec raison par des
statistiques qui remontent à la hausse
de crem de d'épisodes avec armes à feu
de dépression de suicides dans
l'impression qu' il ya beaucoup de
plaies à panser
- patrice parler de ce convoi je vous
laisserai peut-être sur ce qu on n'a
peut-être pas encore vu c'est à dire que
dans le prochain mois mois et demi au
maximum on va avoir une décision majeure
la cour suprême on parle beaucoup
beaucoup de celles qui s'en vient au
sujet de l'avortement est évidemment il
y en a une autre qui touche justement
les armes à feu et c'est très possible
ça y est allé d'une prédiction l'heure
d'une garantie c'est très possible que
la course surtout avec sa composition
actuelle vient démonter une loi qui
vient de l'état new york qui permet
simplement d'oublier les gens qui
voudraient porter une arme de poing à
s'enregistrer et à justifier qu'ils le
fassent en public et c'est même ce même
ceux qui pensent avoir manhwa extrêmes
là on pourrait empêcher la totalité des
juridictions la grandeur du pays
d'imposer ce genre de restrictions l'a
donc si vous pensez que c'est pas beau
ce qu'on voyait pour les partis
reçoivent des armes à feu c'est
difficile de digérer qu'on en ait aussi
peu encore une fois on ne peut être
encore rigoureux à faire merci d'être
venu nous voir comme ça pied levé pour
le panel contenu de cette nouvelle
horrible merci à très bientôt on va
poursuivre nous un martin michel ces
luttes sur l'adoption du projet de loi
96 khz et la loi cas 20 16 maintenant je
vais vous faire entendre
je vous faire entendre l'opposition
non je vous faire entendre monsieur le
groupe si vous le voulez bien excuser
moi je t'aime monsieur legault on à
monsieur legault en extrait et on
revient après qu'on va entendre
l'opposition ensuite
d'un côté le parti libéral votre compte
parce qu'ils trouvent que la loi 96 fois
trop loin puis l'autre côté le parti
québécois votre compte la loi 96 parce
que le parti québécois pensent que ça va
trop passé lointain donc on a deux côtés
un parti qui dit ça va trop loin l'autre
pas assez loin donc on voit que la caq
est dans une position équilibrée ça va
donner très important d'aller chercher
les pouvoirs en matière de regroupement
familial
parce qu'actuellement le gouvernement
fédéral accepte la moitié des migrants
qui parlent pas français dans cette
catégorie
est intéressant parce que là on est en
pleine campagne martine monsieur legault
dit nous on est allé plus loin qu'on
pensait devoir aller pour la langue
française là je veux à les rapatrier la
sélection de la catégorie de
l'immigration de la réunification
familiale et ça se ressent cheval de
bataille pour la prochaine campagne les
déjà en élections voyez c'est ça la
bataille va se faire il ya eu viol et
levier pour faire pression sur ottawa
mais il a gagné son pari sur toute la
ligne il ya polariser juste assez peu
trop et pour se faufiler dans le centre
entre le parti québécois qui trouvent
qu'il va pas assez loin et libéraux qui
trouvent qu'il devra aller plus loin et
c'était parti comme ça dans le projet de
loi a été déposée il ya un an à peu près
exactement jour pour jour les libéraux
avaient dit que c'était beghi c'était
pas mal ce projet de loi là le pq ou 6
alors même qu'au gouvernement on se
disait ben est ce que on est en train de
perdre notre fleuron nationaliste cac et
c'est ce qu'on devra trouver autre chose
alors l'expression en politique si moi
c'est une éternité prend tout son sens
parce que lol
l'échiquier politique a changé les
libéraux sont dans une situation où il
doit sauver les meubles alors là ils ont
revirer leur veste de côté et le pq
aussi veut essayer d'aller gruger du
vote chez les péquistes dur là on voit
les entendant une seconde mais je veux
poursuivre le tour de table a tu sur
michel c'est luc sur loeb
le milieu dont parle monsieur legault
est ce qu il a réussi selon vous michel
et luc atteindre le milieu prenons
l'exemple des cégeps la loi limite le
nombre de places pour les allophones et
francophones dans les cégeps anglophones
mais élimine pas complètement ce droit
comme aurait voulu faire le pq langue du
travail également on éteint les les
droits il ya des dispositions apprendre
le français en six mois il ya des
dispositions comme ça ce que michel il a
réussi son pari du milieu
il y toujours selon monsieur legault 20h
sur la loi de la laïcité il ya 10 heures
/ ca les libéraux sont contre parce que
ça va trop loin et le pe prix qui trouve
pas que ça va c'est vrai donc gérer non
ça fait pas de soi une bonne noah si la
loi n'est pas bonne au départ
il fait toujours ça ils jouent les
oppositions des unes contre les autres
et ça le fait passer pour quelqu'un de
modérer fille dans le milieu alors que
la loi est là elle a ses effets il ya
des choses qui là dedans qui n'ont pas
beaucoup de sens de six mois par exemple
pour dire pour avoir accès il a brandi à
metz et la santé ont continué à bien des
gens oui mais ces recettes des socios
non le ca traîneront il ya toutes sortes
de choses à réconcilier au sein de cette
loi là mêmes qui vont être compliqués
c'est qui est un anglophone historique
qu'ils les ponts ça va être un peu à
l'usure pied du jura voir que tout
beaucoup de ces dispositions là sont
tatillonne qui vont être compliqués
administrés l'udc les verts les enquêtes
qui ont été faites sur des employeurs
quelles sont les exigences que vous avez
en matière de langues à montréal des
employeurs exigent l anglais pour il
n'exigeait pas parce qu'ils possèdent et
exportation où il faisait
partie de leur chiffre d'affaires
il exigeait pour des fins de
communication alain terme même c'est à
dire que les entreprises sont de plus en
plus branché sur le monde branché entre
elles l'anglais de plus en plus
nécessaire est ce que la loi 4 et ça ça
c'est peut-être le facteur pour moi
c'est le facteur qui explique que la
difficulté du français actuellement de
faire valoir le français comme langue de
travail dans des usages langue public
mais surtout dans le travail est ce que
la loi va venir corriger ça pour moi la
réponse est non la loi viendra pas
corriger ça alors la loi ce qu'elle va
faire c'est qu'elle va enfin un peu de
pression sur ceux qui refusait carrément
français pas capables de prendre de
faire trois cours de français au cégep
pas capable de répondre dans un commerce
au français etc oui ça va réviser
quelques cols mais pour tous les
anglophones qui ont fait des efforts le
français ça va rien changer on va
regarder ensemble quelques points
limiter l'accès au cégep anglophone on
le deal donc le pourcentage qui est de
17 pour ça actuellement les anglophones
et les ayants droit sont 9 % ils ont il
ya 17 % des places au québec dans les
cégeps qui sont dans les cégeps
anglophones on plafonne le pourcentage
pas le nombre absolu étant de la loi 101
aux entreprises 24 à 49 employés et
apprendre le français en six mois
autrement dit pour les nouveaux
arrivants pour les réfugiés ce que mon
chef vous en faisait référence à ça
c'est après six mois la communication
avec le gouvernement sont pour la santé
sera faite en français martin est ce que
ça pour dans la population francophone
en général les gens se disent et des
avancées est ce que c'est un plus à
cette campagne qui commence quand même
dans le baluchon de monsieur legault oui
c'est monsieur legault veut c'est quand
même encore les francophones qui font et
défont les gouvernements
monsieur le goût pour dire qu'il a fait
un changement est ce que dans
l'application réelle ça va faire une
différence bell est un autre enjeu je
pense que monsieur le tout à fait raison
ça va être très difficile d'appliquer
cette idée du 6 mois pour les personnes
immigrantes ils vont avoir besoin dead
c'est clair et net c'est extrêmement
difficile d'apprendre le français
surtout dans un délai aussi court
la loi va être contesté aussi devant les
tribunaux on va voir aussi qu'est ce que
le gouvernement fédéral va faire
à court terme monsieur legault pourrait
s'en aller en campagne électorale dans
les campagnes québécoises francophones
et dire qui a fait un pas de plus qu'il
est le premier depuis 40 ans avoir fait
un pas de plus pour protéger la langue
française ok on va écouter l'opposition
après j'ai une question pour vous avant
de vous dire au revoir on écoute donc la
réaction après des partis d'opposition
je vais voter je vais voter pour comme
comme législatrice mais aussi comme
ex-ministre responsable justement de la
protection de la promotion de la langue
française c'est pas un projet de loi qui
qui est parfait mais je pense que c'est
un projet de loi qui a le mérite de
faire avancer la protection de la langue
française ce projet de loi ce n'est pas
la suite de la loi 100 c'est la
continuité de la loi 22 du parti libéral
du québec en 74 il est fier députés du
parti québécois en 1974 on voit tes
contre la loi 22 pourquoi parce que ça
allait passer loin en prenez pas au
sérieux les défis de la langue et
l'histoire se répète on va désamorcer
cette clause de six mois qui s'applique
aux nouveaux arrivants c'est une clause
qui manque de compassion et franchement
c'est une clause qui est sur le terrain
absolument inapplicable
il n'y a pas de raison de faire preuve
d'un peu de discernement
et une partie des extraits ça c'était ce
matin vous avez noté que la députée
indépendante dans mon petit va voter
pour le projet de loi libéral donc à 10
6 est pas parfait mais c'est une avancée
alors ma question à montréal sur le
terrain montréalaise que monsieur
legault est mieux armé ou moins bien
armés parce que là on a 10 pour
l'ensemble du vote francophone martin
c'est un plus pour lui montréal est ce
que il tourne le dos à dos et
conscription qui peut pas atteindre à ce
que comment il voit dans la prochaine
campagne électorale montréal martin tour
de ta bas je pense pas que ça soit sa
priorité montréal parce que simon rien
n'avait été sa priorité il aurait
travaillé les choses différemment il y
le courtisent vraiment c'est le vote
francophone qu'il veut aller chercher
s'il est plus ramassé quelques pays ils
veulent faire mémorial n'est pas la
priorité de la cac michel
aurait elle est vraiment pas la priorité
de la cac et ce qu'ils veulent l'aider à
montréal c'est beaucoup plus ce qui est
arrivé sur l'europe par exemple
la loi 96 mais la loi 96 s'est resserré
un petit peu les boulons ou je suis
obsédé par ça
s'est resserré un petit peu les boulons
des lois sans drain sans rien changer
alors comme il change rien de
fondamental au sûr que ça va changer
grand chose à la situation du français à
montréal mais on l avenir le dira mais
c'est prendre le même cadre des lois
c'est le bon vieux principe la loi 101
marchipont parfum tous deux leur sort
sochaux succès
il ya des éléments dans la loi 96 qui
vont plaire aux gens qui viennent à
montréal par exemple absolu sur l'île de
montréal il ya un bourget point de votre
arme qui va de la caf vont continuer
mais le reste à mon avis ça va pas
changer par contre les couronnes qui
viennent au centre ville une fois de
temps en temps et qui dans la loi il y à
cette obligation de service il y à
l'obligation les trois cours de français
au cégep en disant vous êtes obligés de
respecter un minimum le français lorsque
vous adresser
ça va beaucoup plaire dans les banlieues
ou dans les banlieues dans les gens qui
sont sur le territoire de la grande
région montréalaise et qui viennent
parfois au centre-ville ok mais d'avoir
plus de de poids à montréal la métropole
ce époque c'est pas martin dans les
projets à court terme de la 4 mai la cac
et assez en santé mais les prévisions
lien quand même méchant balayage alors
montréal c'est pas tellement bon s'il ya
des du collatéral ils vont le prendre
effectivement lyon bourges et lyon 1
pointe aux trembles qui peuvent avoir
des visées sur certaines
circonscriptions francophones mais c'est
le projet de loi il est beaucoup plus
pour les régions pour les régions pour
laly francophone et je pense que le coc
raison aussi pour dire que les couronnes
peuvent être séduite par ce projet de
loi là parce que les courants ne
prennent plus la mesure du déclin du
français quand ils vont à montréal et
qui se font servir un anglais alors que
le premier ministre que la caq arrive
avec ce projet de loi là et 10 buts on a
fait quand même pas mais tout est dans
la façon dont on vole l'appliquer ça
vraiment on n'a même pas de critères ça
va être extrêmement difficile de mesurer
les avancées
ici les nouvelles mesures du projet de
loi de la nouvelle loi vent et efficace
parlez-moi de dominique anglade de son
pari ça a été un parcours difficile
compliqué je commence avec l'udc ils ont
proposé quelque chose sur les trois
cours de français de plus dans les
cégeps qui allait être des cours de
programme c'est à dire philosophique etc
or maintenant c'est trois cours de
français de plus de langue française de
plus est ce que madame anglade et l'adq
on parle d'autre chose l'udc
oui elle a d'ailleurs essayé qu'on parle
d'autre chose mais ça n'a pas fonctionné
elle a proposé une loi cadre pour les
régions malheureusement c'est tombé le
jour de la mort de de guy lafleur même
si on sait que le parti québécois qui a
essayé de faire d'approfondir les
questions sur les services à domicile
des soins à domicile et on se rend
compte que plus on se rapproche de
l'élection - les grands programmes de
changement compte et ce qui compte c'est
à dire quoi avec sont des lecteurs et si
ce que madame anglade est en train de
faire elle reconnaît qu'avec son
électorat au moins sauver les meubles
après cd capables de croître cruel le
froid mais d'abord sauvé les meubles
michel c'est martine 30 secondes chacun
michel d'un gros défi pour les libéraux
péquistes on l'a beaucoup d'ironie fait
pour les libéraux aussi un amas glad
syrie dans le pied avec cet amendement
qu'elle a proposé kaunas et de retirer
tous à un moment donné la communauté
anglophone dallas a voulu surtout ce
fait qu'on lui dise écoutez vous n'êtes
pas responsable du clean france est ce
qu'on vous autres qui étaient soit parce
que des anglais montréal que le français
provient elle a même pas réussi à leur
dire ça alors c'est sûr qu'il ya des
gens qui est qui bon et personne qui va
se mettre à bosser pour la cacao dans
l'ouest mais il ya des gens qui seront
pas
c'est comment c'est martin fait partie
tout ça oui
j'ose dire vite fait une règle non
écrite en politique qui dit que ne
jamais séduire un électorat puis
abandonné l'électorat que tu as déjà et
madame anglade français
la réalité un beau match c'est merci à
vous trois merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit